let's begin with the cardinals and this
is the question that we have been asking
as we looked at the teams from the afc
and nfc north yesterday cardinals can't
leave draft weekend without what chris i
i mean i i look at the cardinals there's
a few areas you look at where you could
go hey oh line they can improve you know
corner certainly maybe something there
there's no doubt but the the one thing i
think i come away with more than
anything is
you know
time to look for an edge guy on the
defensive side of the ball you know
chandler jones getting up there in years
yeah you signed j.j watt he's not a real
real edge guy like all the time he's
kind of got interior defensive line
versatility that type of stuff as well
so it's a team that needs has needs but
you know with chandler jones getting up
there in years yes they got marcus
golden back there's no real
you know
what i guess future there and that would
be a position i would think they'd have
to address a little to help their team
out this year and going into the future
just have more of a presence than a
playmaker in that front seven that that
scares football teams that way
they picked up aj green via free agency
to take the spot of larry fitzgerald
presumably we still don't know what
fitzgerald plans to do
in 2021 they could probably use
some help at the tight end position i
would say that would be another one
certainly no doubt about it and and also
with patrick peterson gone even though
they've added malcolm butler who as of
uh last word was debating whether to
he's probably not going to wear patrick
peterson's 21 i mean peterson was there
for 10 years but butler and peterson i
don't know that that's a wash i think
they have some work to do at that
position as well
no definitely that was that was one
thing you know i mentioned off the top
there corner certainly a spot you could
look at malcolm butler buys them some
time you know they did resign robert
alford they got byron murphy jr you know
they got a great buddha baker as far as
safety in the secondary there but yeah i
would think corner is probably another
one of those positions mike that's
that's high on the charts i
edge guy
corner and then really offensive lineman
i think those are the three positions
you look at you know they have some
offensive linemen there you just don't
know how they're going to shuffle them
around who's going to play what exactly
are they looking for i mean offensive
tackle i think is something you could
certainly sit there and look at too that
would be tossed around in that first
round conversation with what is it they
got pick 16 i believe something right
around that air that area uh to where i
think that could make sense too hey
protect kyla murray they got some guys
there that are career journey men or
guys that are hopeful maybe you know
that could play tackle but uh i don't
know if there's anything you can look at
there to just go hey wow that's special
we're set at that position for a long
long time
the rams draft needs can be summarized
simply by saying they need more teams to
which they can trade their draft picks
because that's what they like to do no
first round picks exercise since 2016
and their first round picks have all
been traded since 2016 through 20 23
which is amazing they do have a second
round pick and two in the third
what do they need to have chris
coming out of this draft weekend to me
the the biggest thing that when you look
at the rams i mean and again this is a
team that's very top-heavy i mean it is
it is
superstars at the top not a lot of depth
behind it you know so they could use
depth and things like that everywhere
but for the number one position for me
would be like linebacker stand-up
linebacker somebody in the middle of
that defense there to get more
production out of that and we know the
front four is pretty special with aaron
donald and leonard floyd you know the
secondary they got some young talented
guys that go along with jalen ramsey as
superstar you know i look at the two
biggest needs for their football team is
either be in that middle linebacker
position to fly around make tackles do
things like that or maybe offensive line
but i come away with middle linebacker
as being maybe the biggest need for the
for this football team
you know they lost a couple of guys from
the secondary troy hill and josh johnson
so they need to do some work there also
michael brocker's traded to the lions
that delayed reaction transaction
between the rams and detroit after
brockers went on record to say what an
upgrade matthew stafford was over jared
goff now they're teammates again so the
defensive line a little bit of a hit but
you're right they got a lot of stars you
got a lot of money devoted to the stars
and that means you got a lot of other
areas that you have to address
and you need depth everywhere everywhere
they need good depth because you get one
of those star players injured you got a
major problem with your football team
because you're relying upon a bunch of
young guys and inexperienced guys to
step up because you don't have the
luxury to have money left over to sign
capable veterans to come in and be your
understudies that is the risk the rams
are taking this year chris
um with stafford
and desean jackson joining the offense
yeah is that enough look desean jackson
great when he's healthy but
it's like it's like a solar eclipse when
he's healthy i know
and it's in it's over before you even
have a chance to appreciate it
i feel like they need a young guy who
can get down the field
nearly as quickly as desean jackson can
when he's healthy yeah i mean he's just
icing on the cake i mean you hope he's
healthy and can be that target that can
scare defenses and stafford could launch
a few 50-yard bombs you know every game
to him and do all that robert woods we
know is all purpose awesome at
everything cooper cup is really damn
good same type of guy all purpose can do
everything the other guy i think too
is is van jefferson a receiver they
drafted i want to say that was late in
the second round last year might have
been early third somewhere in that but
he's another guy not mike to necessarily
a deep threat guy but
another guy that i think is just the
versatility in can do everything woods
and cooper cup can do there's no
weakness to his game so you can't pin
any of those receivers to one little
aspect of their team they all do the
same stuff and of course they get a
decent tight end to go along with it so
yeah i mean desean jackson is risky
you're right about that but i do think
there's enough weapons to go around and
we know the rams they're gonna play
three receivers you know it's gonna be
one back one tight end three receivers
they like to live in that personnel set
and we're going to see what mcveigh can
do with it and all the trickeration and
and you know magician stuff he can come
up with the offense behind stafford this
year
by the way rams receiver robert woods is
going to join us live on thursday
morning so i'll have a chance to ask him
directly that's awesome he's hoping the
team adds now that matthew stafford is
there at quarterback seattle seahawks
another team from the nfc west without a
first-round pick this is the first of
two straight years where their first
round pick goes to the jets for jamal
adams they have second round pick fourth
round pick seventh round pick not a
whole lot there for the seahawks
what do we expect them to do what do
they need to do in this draft chris well
it's the defensive side of the ball i
think that's the first thing i look at
and you know corner issues and maybe
interior d-line are the two things i
look at more than anything
to just go the seahawks need upgrades
there hey they lost jaron reid they're
not real
dep i mean deep as far as interior d
lyman you know puna ford's a good player
there's no doubt about that but there's
no superstar difference maker in there
and then corner is the other position
mike yeah they lose shaquille griffin
and free agency uh they got trey flowers
but they don't have like to me my corner
is the position i look at to where they
need upgrade they got to come away the
draft with one maybe two corners
i mean they're a team you look at they
just they're not very good at man-to-man
they don't have that guy that can do
that so i don't know where that where it
goes uh but to me i think corner is
probably the one position i look at more
than any that they could really really
use
yeah and i think one thing that they
definitely need to to be doing now is
scouting all the quarterbacks all the
ones that they think will be there round
two and thereafter that's where they
found russell wilson round three back in
2012. they can't wait until next year
and get caught flat-footed when wilson
moves on sure and i still think there's
a chance look the talk's not going away
that something's gonna happen we've
talked in the past about june 1 being a
critical date for any trade of russell
wilson because of that 39 million dollar
cap charge the seahawks would take if
they traded him before june 1.
and there's nothing that stops the
seahawks from entering into a deal with
a team draft weekend to do the deal as
of june 2. we see that all the time in
january deal is going to be done middle
of march nothing stops two teams from
reaching a tentative deal that they're
going to do a trade and they're going to
put the paperwork through on june the
2nd and that could happen draft weekend
as well but if they don't trade russell
wilson i think the time has come to have
another quarterback that they are
developing and that they are grooming
and that they are evaluating for being
the future in the event that this year
is the last year for russell wilson in
seattle chris yeah well they got to
think of something for sure and i mean
listen i mean when it gets close to
draft weekend or that week i mean of
course we're i think we're all going to
be standing at attention a little bit
just to you know wonder will that be one
last you know push one last effort by
the seahawks to make a move do something
like that it's going to be interesting
to see where that goes but yeah they got
to be thinking that about that to a
degree um
life after russ it certainly seems like
the writing's on the wall with that that
whole conversation and they're a team
that hey quite honestly listen i look at
them they're good i don't think they're
super bowl caliber as you look at them
right now they they need some help
there's no doubt about that you know on
both sides of the ball they could use a
little polish but that defensive side of
the ball certainly needs some help
and you know the other side of this uh
the possibility that they could make a
move to try to get into the top ten and
use russell wilson as
the trade bait to make it happen that
that becomes necessarily a pre-june one
transaction you can't do half the trade
you can't say russell wilson doesn't get
moved off the roster until june two but
we're going to take your first round
pick in 2021 that's the problem if they
would want to try to move wilson and get
in position to get one of the top guys
this year chris they got to take the 39
million cap charge and i just don't know
that they're ready to do that no i i
hear that that's that's a huge hit and
you know for a team that's you know like
we said got some issues some holes to
fill everything like that i think
ultimately that's what stops that from
happening this year and then it's 2022
we see some real action as far as wilson
and a trade and everything like that
it would be a hell of a story though if
the seahawks traded wilson to the team
that holds the third overall pick
because that team is in the division the
san francisco 49ers we know what they're
doing
by moving up to three they're taking a
quarterback what else must they get
this year in the draft well yeah right
we know they're moving to three to take
a quarterback definitely after that i
look at their needs a little bit like i
just we just talked about with the
seattle seahawks you know offensively i
mean there's a lot of good offensive
lines in a good spot we know they got
good receivers you know running backs
pretty damn good shanahan always seems
to add to that group at some point in
the draft but but i think you look at it
richard sherman's gone jason veretz
there yes but he's been injured you know
90 percent of his career
after that there's no marquee guy as far
as a cover corner the 49ers the way yes
i look at it more than anything to go
corner you know followed by another
player on the d line maybe another guy
off the edge because of the deford and
you know the issues he's having with
injuries that way and they don't have
that other guy opposite of nick bosa but
i think it's definitely defense and i
think corner is the one i look at more
than anything mike to go yeah they need
more talent and they need more quality
depth there at the position you know
when this draft is all said and done
and you know think back to 2012 when
washington made the big move up to
number two took a quarterback there took
a quarterback in the fourth round
different reason
for that
rg3 followed by kirk cousins because the
shanahans were there not really on board
with rg3 kirk cousins was more to their
liking but i think that somewhere in the
later rounds of the draft it would be
smart to get a guy who could be
developed as the future backup because
we know jimmy garoppolo is not going to
be there for very long right so why not
at least evaluate the quarterback class
all the way through since you're looking
at him anyway maybe there's a guy that
trickles through it around five six or
seven who can be the understudy to
whoever they take at number three
overall because that's one of the major
problems we've seen the past few years
jimmy g gets hurt yeah and the guys they
put in can't get it done chris no i i
know you know
there's no doubt about that now you know
that i don't think that's a crazy
thought mike at all i think that could
be a possibility they do have you know
josh rosen right they did just sign nate
sudfeld i believe probably thinking a
little bit of what you're doing mike or
what you're talking about you know hey
we're we're gonna draft a qb at three
you know there's a good chance jimmy g
won't be here all right now who are we
gonna have behind our quarterback and
you know in case something happens you
know with that rookie quarterback so uh
that's got to be on their radar as far
as addressing that quarterback situation
addressing the backup situation because
yeah they've been bit by that bug a few
times over the last few years
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports